there exists in dota a prestigious award
a digital medal handed out only to the
most heroic players the players who
sacrifice themselves for the team the
players who persevere through every
hardship the players who feed
incessantly and still make it out the
other side that award is the melk award
and it is given to players who do
incredible things in the face of
unbelievable KTX
the melk award is somehow both an honor
and a dig on the player that burns it it
represents teamwork sacrifice
perseverance and perhaps most
importantly incessant feeding it
requires one player to go through a game
with zero kills in at least 20 deaths
and then still somehow win its lose
impossible but this man Bennett it's fun
it's it's great they have their fun we
won the game everyone wins
the meme was created the community wins
the Malka war was born when Jacob of
male taught Anderson was playing on eg
in the ancient days of 2012 Malik was
playing position for for eg and the team
was still trying to get their feet on
the ground I think it's a lot of player
they have to settle down for 3rd place I
think it is already something to be
achieved at least getting a 3rd place in
such a huge tournament as a newly formed
team of complete international players
mm-hmm but I think they have so
disappointed sown their beds but it was
the early days of dota 2 and it was a
total Wild West and that meant the teams
like the 2012 mousesports roster could
drive high so how are you spending your
time in Seattle so far if you're not
gaming masturbating sorry masturbating
so essentially we're playing this mean
team from Mouse walks you know they have
all these dumbasses on their roster how
hard was that game they have seen seeing
I think and they have Trixie they have
all these morons who don't know how to
win in DotA they know how to have fun
though and I respect that first gaming
is ultimately about having fun first and
foremost
all right thank you very much things
thing for coming on the show
good luck in the future games and we'll
see you later thank you [ __ ] same
thing but if Mauser leaning in the
online joindota masters League eg were
taking things seriously they found
themselves ahead in gold but behind in
XP in the early game thanks to a few
early kills from that the XP gruff why
is it going the way of male sports we
are gonna see if enemies to getting
ripped off inside the treats once again
smells backed into a corner unwillingly
with Vanguard a shackle drums shiver and
milk is very good in after scoring a few
early kills on Melton venomancer they
thought it'd be hilarious to just keep
killing them so they did and it's Treacy
gonna find milk hiding inside the trees
over Lacoste wants to go in for a black
hole as well but on the people affair
and the first one to die over over Marat
a final against overall MLA kid mouth
Aaron's gonna fly his own safety bamboo
he's gonna go in and over although he
might need to smoke something around now
milk is he a Gulch at his school and I
mean Trixie
well Ichi was warming well and maintain
a gold lead for most of the game mouse
still had the XP advantage and it was
going to matter all along don't crowd
has finally been announced bolts from
the style of the game we're 55 minutes
in a mass balls have only just got the
advantage as far as gold goes
XP they've had it since the start
basically by the end of the game
Milka died 20 times without picking up a
single kill but it wasn't for lack of
trying
while now decided to be hilarious to
keep killing milk he's trying to help
his team win and even though he kept
dying sometimes you get the chance to
pop his ultimate first venom answers
poison Nova ability can't actually kill
any
it creates a ring of poison that spreads
out and deals damage over time to every
enemy in it but it leaves them at 1 hp
that means that even though melts had
tons of damage to Mouse he never
actually gotten the kill credit for bit
but the rest of his team did middle lane
gotta be careful they realize a little
bit buildings a town a name a job that
the black cat just read but it doesn't
rag tea with a shackle hold fear there
but feet hold his loins
they say pop y'all before he's gonna die
yeah just right-clicked him to death
it didn't matter much though both teams
were kind of a mess eg were effectively
playing with only four heroes and while
mouths were winning fights they weren't
winning hard enough to end the game my
first 10 deaths some of them should have
been avoided by me some of them was just
a good play by them when we go into the
later stages of the game by all means we
should have lost they had a full
inventory more fleeing they were decked
out on all their heroes do I even want
to look at the Gulf a minute it doesn't
matter it doesn't even matter see us we
don't even need to give a crap at 564 CS
18144 morphling Trixie's meme is even a
smiley face right now he is grinning it
through his old name and he G of how
much barmy is God they by all means
should have one with the lineup they had
what they did though they realized oh
this guy has so many deaths let's just
see how many we can keep on adding on to
that you know I think at some point in
the game some of them would like right
XD and sit and talk about how funny this
was he's got more destined levels and so
after over an hour of play
eg decided it was time to keep forcing
themselves into mouse's base until it
stuck but not before milk died one more
time the fortifications let's go get up
that sleep of the radiant side serum
comes in will it be enough ravage will
pop
mouth gets gone and while milk may have
died one last time Iggy's creeps finally
managed to close out the game after an
hour and 26 minutes in the meantime Rexy
trying to hold up an openness DJ hey
guys through the rear the mega creeps
take it they take out the throne while
Mouse boys try the
they know what was to push down on AJ
melt finished the game zero 20 and 21
and EJ still managed to win that seems
impossible but there's a few reasons for
why it happened for one mouse was really
only focused on killing male and another
thing was that it was still eating only
days of dota2 and people just weren't as
good at playing the game as they are now
wait-wait-wait-wait-wait the DA just
used the cliff what
that's why lycost went lowland all chat
I think somebody missed clicked the
glyph oh man it's a truck but the stat
line stuck it became an award the player
who manages to go 20 death without a
single kill and still win the game
doesn't deserve recognition it's mostly
applied to amateur games where players
casters and pros alike have witnessed
heroes who have bravely given themselves
over to the melka worn hallowed halls
and esteemed recipients I've had a
decent amount of years to sort of get
used to it I think I very rarely meet
people for the first time without them
remembering at that particular game so
I'm I'm very used to the fact that
people bring it up
I've also hosted or not hosted but I've
been on the desk in so many tournaments
where my co analysts keep bringing it up
and finding it amusing when Paul was new
to 2 dota 2 he also used it as a
cornerstone of his mockery and finally
last but not least our panel wouldn't be
complete without a star named a former
pro player with expert knowledge and
predictions and a popular figure with
the community sadly we could only get
milk I've had to grow some some hot skin
whenever that was brought up and milk
himself is totally okay with the fact
that his name is attached to what isn't
exactly the most prestigious award in
DotA history that's probably because he
won the game I don't know man
I don't know
go next and honestly that's what makes
the milk award so impressive Malcolm did
him more in death than he did in life
and as he found a way to use the fact
that he was dying so often to their
advantage dota is unique among MOBAs and
that deaths don't matter as much as they
do in a game like say League of Legends
so you can actually make it back despite
having a player on your team who has
more deaths than two levels dota is a
game of teamwork and that means that
even if someone who looks like they're
feeding it might just be an elaborate
plan concocted by their team to win or
they might be getting camp bison trolls
either way they'll get an award for it
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]